benjamin mendy is used to the acclaim of
football fans as a multiple premier
league winner and world cup champion
the manchester city player arrived at
court to hear how that status of wealth
was allegedly exploited and he was a
sexual predator away from the pitch
described to the jury as a reasonably
famous player the frenchman hasn't
played since being suspended last august
by the club that paid 52 million pounds
for him
the case involves 13 women as young as
17 years old being targeted for sex
eight counts of rape being defended by
mendy along with separate charges of
attempted rape and sexual assault
there was the prosecution says a callous
indifference for the victims the pursuit
of women was turned into a game by mendy
with no regard for their pain or
distress he and a fixer friend are
accused of repeatedly not taking no for
an answer
opening the prosecution case timothy
craig qc said it is another chapter in a
very old story men who rape and sexually
assault women because they think they
are powerful and because they think they
can get away with it
the jury was shown footage inside and
outside mendy's home south of manchester
the isolation reinforcing the sense of
vulnerability the victims feeling
trapped or isolated in a rural cheshire
mansion featuring a swimming pool cinema
and rooms lockable only from the inside
likened to panic rooms
one woman working at a nightclub is said
to have been procured by co-defendant
louis sahar maturi as a potential victim
for mendy she is alleged to be offered
cash to go to mendez home where she felt
pressurized into having sex against her
will by the 28 year old
three women were also said to have been
raped at a pool party
mendy was at the peak of his career for
club and country between 2018 and last
year when the offences alleged to have
happened
he won the 2018 world cup with france
and the premier league three times in
manchester city
the jury heard that mendy and his friend
weren't in some happy state of sexual
ignorance but aware of what they were
doing taking control of their victims
mendy maturi denial the charges the case
continues
rob harris sky news chester crown court